the european union extends a welcoming
hand to ukraine this week
in the hope that its government will
still fulfill the conditions needed to
sign major partnership
and trade deals ukraine has decided to
suspend preparations for signing an
association agreement
and a deep and comprehensive free trade
area pact
at the european partnership summit in
lithuania but eu leaders say the offer
a major package designed to help ukraine
survive its deep economic
problems remains on the table if kiev
meets benchmarks in three areas
the government must ensure that
elections respect international
standards
address the issue of selective justice
and make sure it doesn't happen again
and implement business reforms the eu
insists that it will not
force ukraine to choose between it and
any other regional bloc
nor does it want closer relations with
eastern partners to come at the expense
of ties with russia
but eu leaders disapprove of the
pressure
moscow has put on kiev not to sign the
agreements
the eastern partnership helps the eu to
strengthen cooperation and trade with
six countries
armenia azerbaijan georgia moldova
belarus and ukraine i am looking forward
to the eastern partnership summit in
vilnius in november
it will be an important moment for
taking important decisions for the
european union
and our eastern neighbours the summit in
vilnius is expected to see moldova and
georgia
initial their association agreements a
preliminary step
to signing them